the best thing Zuck could do right now
the best things I could do right now is
stop coming up with ideas it's not your
strength
go find the biggest badass innovator
creative that wants to prove a point
give him a fat salary with a big upside
let them come in rather than coming up
with ideas go find your Roger rails go
find your next Sandburg go find your
next recruit this is recruiting season I
think the approach he's taken is not
going to work out because he's not a
vision guy he's an Executor and by the
way zucks are very very hard to find
very very hard to find there's a reason
why he's worth what he's worth but he
can go find the other guys they're out
there
[Music]